[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEITH DANEKIND: Welcome to
the "Apigee Up Close" webcast.
We do these twice a
month, and the topics
change based on demand.
Hi, I'm Keith Danekind.
I'm an Apigee customer engineer.
So for today's
agenda, we're going
to do a brief overview of API
management and Apigee Edge.
Then I'm going to do
a demo on Apigee Edge
and show you a few
things in there.
And then I'll take
some questions.
Let's get started.
So let's talk about
API management.
Let's consider a scenario.
Let's suppose you've got
some services over there
on the right-hand
side, so anything
you happen to have around
REST services, SOAP
services, microservices,
maybe it's
your Service Bus,
anything over there.
We've got some folks over
here on the left-- partners,
employees, customers-- and
they have applications.
And those applications need to
get data from these services.
There's a need to control what
those applications can do,
and how they can access that
data and how frequently,
and things like that.
That's where API
management comes in.
That's where Apigee
Edge fits in here.
So we put Apigee Edge
in here to control
how those applications can
access that right-hand side.
Now, we also have to think
about application developers,
the people who write
all those applications.
How will they gain
access to these systems?
What do we need to do in
order to get them credentials
so that Apigee will let them
into those backend services?
How will they read
documentation?
How will they learn
how your APIs work?
And how will they
sign up for access?
Along the way, as traffic
starts to flow through here,
we'd also like to be able
to create some reports that
tells us about which
applications are accessing
this, what they're doing, how
frequently they're calling,
what's the level of traffic, how
does it compare to past trends
and things like that.
So a few more things
we want to do.
We could use Apigee in
here to build a facade
over the backend services.
We can present one
set of interfaces
to those external applications
compared to what's inside.
We can control access so
different applications might
have access to
different services,
and they might get different
things when they call them.
We can rate limit to protect
those backend services.
If one of those applications
is calling too quickly,
we can shut it down.
We can also impose some quotas.
Maybe we want to give
developers limited access
to some of these things, and
we may want to charge money
for other things.
We can add caching in there
to improve performance.
So if we already have the
answer in Apigee Edge,
we don't need to
call the backend.
We could reformat that
request as it comes in
and make it appropriate
for those backend services.
The response that comes
from the backend services,
we could change that around
too before we send it
back to the applications.
We could manage a whole
collection of those app
developers out there and
manage their credentials.
And along the way, we could
collect usage analytics.
And that would give us
some insights into how
our API program is going.
So these are all
things you might
want to do with an API
management platform.
And this is a good overview
of what API management is.
There's a new way to think
about the problem of services.
Traditionally, we
would have thought
of this as an exposure problem.
So we've got some data, we need
to expose it through a service.
But there's a better way to
think about this, a pattern
that we've seen our most
successful customers adopt.
And that's to think
about it from the outside
in, meaning that rather
than just thinking
about exposing a service, what
we're actually thinking about
is the end user who will
use the application.
What's that user's experience?
What is it like to use the
application that they're using?
And how do we
empower the developer
who writes that application?
That comes from
having great APIs
and building a set
of APIs that are very
nice to use for that developer.
And that's what
the API team does.
So if we think about this
from the outside inward,
we'll have much better success.
There are a lot of people
who use Apigee Edge.
What's interesting for me
when I look at this slide is,
I'd look at all the
different businesses
that these people are in.
What they all have
in common is, they're
seeing success from
having an API program,
either internal or external.
So let's look at Apigee Edge.
Apigee Edge is an API
management platform.
And we can think of it
in three major parts.
We can think of it as
a set of APIs services.
That's the part
that routes traffic.
That's the thing that we
put between the applications
and the services.
And we can think of
some needs in there
along the lines of security,
transforming messages, acting
as an enterprise
gateway, orchestrating
those backend services,
and preventing people
from abusing those services.
In terms of
developer engagement,
we need to have a
developer portal.
And that's a good place to put
documentation for developers
to come who want to
consume these APIs
and read about how to use them.
There's a need to
have API products,
so a way to take
all these services
and bundle them together
into different packages that
provide different access.
And there may be
a need to monetize
services, where we're going
to charge money for access.
Finally, we need a way
to measure everything.
And that's where API
Analytics comes in.
We can measure
developer engagement,
we can measure
business metrics, we
can look at operational
metrics, API program metrics.
And we can monitor the platform
to see how it's working.
So all of this together makes
an API management platform.
So what's the difference between
an API Gateway and an API
management platform?
Well, an API Gateway
is a small subset
of an API management platform.
As you can see from this slide,
an API management platform
does a lot more than you would
do with a simple gateway.
So gateway would
do basic things,
like collect security tokens.
But there's a lot more to
solving the API problem
than there is with
a simple gateway.
So let's talk about
some advantages
that Apigee has over other
solutions in the marketplace.
In Gartner's recent
Magic Quadrant survey,
they found Apigee
to be a Leader.
And they ranked Apigee highest
in terms of the ability
to execute and the
completeness of their vision.
You can find more about
this on the Apigee website.
There are a few
different options
in terms of how
you deploy Apigee.
Apigee is offered as a
software as a service
managed in Google Cloud.
You can run it on
premises, in a data center.
You can run it in the
cloud of your choice.
Or you can run hybrid, where
most of it runs in the cloud,
and some of it's going to run
near your computing resources.
These are all different options
for running Apigee Edge.
Apigee Edge offers global
scale and availability.
It's hosted in 13 data
centers around the world.
And historically, we had
99.999% availability.
The Developer Portal
within Apigee Edge
can be easily customized
to meet your needs.
If this is an
internal portal, you
might keep it kind of simple.
But if it's external
facing, you might
want to brand it to match
your branding of your website.
Apigee gives you a choice
between configuration
or coding.
There's a number of
out-of-the-box policies that do
basic things.
That's what we're
seeing on the left here.
You can drop in these policies
to request an access token
or add response caching.
If you want to do
code-driven development,
you can build your own
policies, and you can drop those
in and mix them with the
out-of-the-box policies.
And that can be done with
JavaScript, Java, or Python.
And you can also
host Node.js in here.
Apigee Edge has a
wonderful analytic system.
You can use it to provide
real-time visibility
into the activity in the system.
You can also use it
to measure and grow
your digital ecosystem.
So you can look at
operational metrics,
but you can also look
at business metrics.
Apigee offers monetization.
So if you decide you want to
charge for access to your APIs,
there's a monetization
add-on that you
can get for Apigee to do this.
You can do revenue-sharing
models, fee-based models,
or freemium models.
Maybe the first
100 calls are free,
and if you want
something more than that,
then you have to pay.
Apigee Sense is another option.
You can add Apigee Sense
to do bot detection
and detect malicious traffic.
So you won't necessarily
see this in the demo today,
but Apigee has a collection
of management APIs.
And these let you control
every aspect of the platform
programmatically through
a REST-based API.
This can be used to automate
operation of Apigee.
Maybe you want to automate
the creation of users
or credentials for people.
Or maybe you want to
use this to push things
into production
automatically after running
a series of tests.
There's APIs to do all of that.
There's a wonderful community
and a bunch of resources
to help you with Apigee.
So there's community.apigee.com
with over 10,000 users.
We've got a series of
four-minute videos, one
for each feature in the product.
You can go in and learn
about the spike arrest
in four minutes, for example.
There's a number of
webcasts that are out there.
You can find those on YouTube.
There's customer stories,
where we interview customers,
and they talk about what
they do with Apigee.
And we publish a
bunch of ebooks.
All of these are great
resources to help you become
productive with the platform.
So let's look at a demo.
What we're going to look
at in the demo today
is a simple set of
APIs that sit on top
of a set of weather data.
The weather data is in BigQuery.
And there's weather stations
from all around the world.
You can look those up by
latitude and longitude.
And for any given
weather station,
you can pull down
historical weather.
So this is what I've got.
On the back, all the way on
the right-hand side here,
we've got weather data
stored in BigQuery.
In order to get
at that data, I've
got to log in using a service
account in Google Cloud.
And in order to get
credentials for that,
I have to talk to Cloud
Identity and Access Management.
So I'm going to send some
credentials over there.
And it's going to return
to me an OAuth token.
And with every request I make
into the weather database,
I've got to send that
credential as a header.
On the left-hand side
of this, I didn't
want to have that security.
So what I'm doing instead
is, I'm using API keys.
So I have a single-page
web application,
I've got a few
mobile applications.
Each of those has
their own API key.
So I'm splitting the security
into two different parts here,
the backend security and
the frontend security.
There's some other things
I'm going to do on here also.
I want to build off a
facade on that backend,
hide away the details
of where this data is.
And I want to control
access to some features
so only limited things
you can do in here.
I want to rate limit to
protect that backend.
I don't want people
calling us too much.
And I'm going to
impose some quotas.
So depending on which
API product you're using,
you'll have different quotas.
And I'm going to add
caching to help performance.
I'm going to reformat the
request as it comes in
and the response when
it comes back in order
to make this more
friendly to my developers
that want to use this API.
In the demo, we're going to
consider three perspectives.
The first one is the application
developer/API consumer.
And that person might be
saying, "All I want to do
is build an application.
Make it easy for me to
consume your services."
We'll look at the API developer.
They might be saying,
"I need to share
a service with other people,
but with some limits."
And we'll look at the API team.
And they might be
saying, "I want
to think about APIs
as software products.
There are customers,
lifecycles, versions.
I want to measure my
program and tune it."
As a developer, I might start
here on the Developer Portal.
From here, I can get
what I need in order
to be productive with these
APIs and to start using them
in my application.
I see there's a number of
API products and something
that says Get Started on here.
Let's look at the
available API products.
So I can see that there
are a few APIs available.
Let's look at this one.
So here's some documentation
on how these APIs work.
I'm looking at the
Weather Stations API.
There's the URL in there.
And it looks like I
can put in a location.
And I need an API key.
And then it'll give me a
list of weather stations.
So I'd like to
actually try this out.
To do that, I'm going to go up
and register a new application.
We'll call it the
webcast demo app.
And we're going to
go with this package.
Now, that's registered
my application,
and I've got an API key.
Let's go back to the
docs and give this a try.
I'll put my API key in there.
And we'll put it in location.
I'm near Boulder, Colorado.
Let's check the
weather for there.
And I see a list
of weather stations
that are near Boulder, Colorado.
So what I like about this is, I
can try out the API right here.
And I can get an idea of
what I need to send in,
and what will come
back in the response.
And that makes me
pretty productive.
I could start coding
at this point.
So I visited the
Developer Portal.
I read the documentation
on how to use the API.
And then I registered
an application,
and that returned
the key for me.
I took the key over
to the documentation,
and I was able to
test it out in there.
And I have a pretty
good feel for what
it's like to call the API now.
So I can make a call in
here and get data back.
The next thing to do is,
let's write an application.
So I've got a simple application
that I've written here.
And what this
allows you to do is,
you can search for
weather stations
by typing in an address
or landmark up here.
And then you get back a
list of weather stations.
And you can check for high
and low temperature data
at that particular
weather station.
So I'm near Boulder, Colorado.
Let's look and see what weather
stations are around here.
So I type in this location.
And it's going to find
me weather stations
that are near that location.
They get populated down here.
So it looks like
it's found a few.
I'm going to go with this
one, specify a year in here.
And then I can run a query.
And that's going to pull down
the historical temperature
data.
This is for the
Boulder location, 2015.
And we can see the
high temperature
data and the low
temperature data in here.
So not bad.
This was pretty easy to write.
It took me about an hour.
Most of it was spent trying
to format these graphs
and to make them look nice.
I added this little
status button
down here so we could
see what was returned.
I got a nice 200 there.
If I run this a few times,
let's see what happens.
So I called too quickly,
and I got shut down
with some rate limiting.
So that's our
simple application.
Let's switch roles
to the API developer
and see what we had to build
in order to make this possible.
So as the API developer, there's
a few things I'm going to do.
What I did when I was building
this particular demo was,
first thing I did
was fire up Postman.
And I called my backend
service a few times,
and played around with it,
read documentation and figured
out what it could do.
And that influenced
what I wanted
to do in terms of building
an API proxy for it.
So once I decided
on that, and I was
happy with how the back service
works, I came into here.
And then I built a specification
to describe my API.
Let's look at that.
So here's my Weather
History API spec.
I've described how it works and
the three different services
you might call
underneath there-- one
to look up weather stations,
one to look up temperature data,
and one to look up wind data.
And I've specified
all that in here.
I can see what the documentation
is going to look like.
I've specified what
the results look like.
So this should give my
developers a good idea
of exactly how this works.
So the next step is
to build an API proxy.
You might come to this
screen under API Proxies
and hit this Plus
Proxy button up here.
So we have a few
choices in here.
Reverse proxy, the first
one, is the most common.
And this is where I started.
You can use an OpenAPI
spec if you have one.
Or you can just
start with the URL,
and make a straight
through connection,
and start to build up
your proxy from there.
The few other options
in here-- if I
was working with a SOAP service,
I might choose this second one.
And that gives me an option
to build either a straight
through connection to
an existing SOAP service
or to possibly
build something that
does SOAP-to-REST and
REST-to-SOAP conversion.
I'd supply the WSDL, and it
would build something for me.
I might use No Target if
I wanted to mock this up.
So what it does in
that case is, Apigee
is going to return the
response, and it's not going
to talk to a backend system.
So I might mock up the
response inside of this proxy.
And I could use that to provide
sample data to my developers.
Hosted Target and Node.js allows
me to host Node.js in here.
And I might do that if I
were going to orchestrate
several backend systems.
And I want the
backend that's called
by Apigee to be this
Node.js code that
then calls other services.
And if someone sent me a proxy
bundle that they've developed,
I would use this last
option to import it.
So I entered my spec, and that
created my API proxy for me
and put me into the editor.
So let's look at that.
So let's look at
the existing API.
This is where I'll develop the
API that outside consumers are
going to use.
Key things to notice here are
Target Endpoints down there.
And this is the backend URL
that's going to be called.
So instead of calling
that directly,
my consumers will now call
one of these URLs up here.
That talks to Apigee, and
then Apigee sends the request
to the backend.
We also have, you'll notice,
there's two different URLs
here.
I have a few different
environments I can deploy into.
In my demo environment
here, I have
a test and a
production environment
that's available to me.
And I have version
7 in production
and version 8 in test.
So they'll call those URLs to
talk to the backend system.
It'll be managed by Apigee.
And traffic will
flow back and forth.
So let's dig in a little further
and see what's over in Develop.
So we're over here
on the Develop tab.
And what we'll
notice in here is,
there's a few different
sections to the screen.
We go through those, and then
I'll go into some details.
So up here, we have
a graphical depiction
of the request and
the response flow.
So the request comes in,
goes to the backend target,
and then the
response comes back.
And along the way, we can
have some of these policies
in place, so they are going
to help manage this request
and response flow.
Those policies are configured
down here at the bottom.
So I'll click on one of these.
And you can see how it's
configured at the bottom.
Policies that I've used in
here are listed over here.
I can reuse these.
I can drag and drop
them over here.
Things to the request go on the
top, things for the response
go on the bottom.
We have two sections down
here, Proxy Endpoints
and Target Endpoints.
Proxy Endpoints
control what happens
between the client and Apigee.
And Target Endpoints
control what happens
between Apigee and the backend.
So for Proxy Endpoints, there's
a few different flows in here.
The PreFlow is executed
unconditionally
at the beginning.
So people might put different
things on the end of the URL.
They might call this in
different ways with a POST,
or a PUT, or GET, or
something like that.
We may want to have the system
behave differently depending
on how they're calling it.
So PreFlow is always called
first, unconditionally.
I tend to put things
in here like checking
for security tokens and rate
limiting and things like that.
The next few that I've got
in here are conditional.
So I can click in here,
and I can add a new one.
And I can choose a
path, and a verb,
and some sort of condition.
So those are called
conditionally.
So if somebody calls my
URL with slash stations
at the end, that gets called if
they call that with a HTTP GET.
Same thing for
temperature and wind.
And then PostFlow is called
unconditionally at the end,
after the others execute.
So first PreFlow, anything
conditional, and then PostFlow.
The same conditions hold
true for the Target backends.
In my case, I've
only got one backend.
And I don't have any
specific logic in there.
But let's imagine we had a bunch
of different backend systems.
And we might be doing some
dynamic routing among them.
We can have different
conditions in here
for those different endpoints.
Down here, I've
got some Resources.
So these are JavaScript
files in this case.
So things like
code and files that
are associated with this
API proxy go down here.
And I've got JavaScript
policies that
reference some source code.
And that's the source
code right there.
So let's look a little bit
in more detail in here.
So we have a few policies
in place up here.
Where did they come from?
I came over to here and I
hit the Plus Step button.
And inside of here,
I'm greeted with a menu
of possible policies that
I could put in there.
There's a few things
around traffic management.
There's some around security,
some around mediation,
and then some extensions.
So let's look at
each section here.
Traffic Management is going
to do basic traffic management
things.
So Quota-- quota would
limit how many times
you can call something in
a certain period of time.
So maybe I want to limit
this to 100 calls per day.
Spike Arrest is going
to limit how it's
called but based on frequency.
So think of this like
a circuit breaker.
You don't want somebody
to call this too fast.
I might set this to 100
transactions per second.
And if they call at a
rate greater than that,
it'll return an error.
We have several
policies for caching,
so basic Response
Cache and the ability
to manipulate these different
caches programmatically.
You can have named
caches, multiple caches.
They're going to have
different times to live.
And you can use them at
different points in your flows.
For security, we've got a
number of options in here.
Basic Auth is going to request
a username and password
from somebody who is
calling the system.
Or it can be used to
construct a header
to send to a backend
system that expects it.
The next three
policies are there
to make sure that bad
things don't get through
in the request.
We have a full
implementation of OAuth 2.
We can check OAuth tokens,
we can generate OAuth tokens.
For backwards compatibility,
there's some OAuth 1.0 in here.
We have the ability
to verify API keys.
Access Control would
let us limit calls
to a certain range
of IP addresses.
We can blacklist or
whitelist certain IP ranges.
If we need to generate
or validate SAML,
we have SAML assertions in here.
And we can work with JWTs.
Under mediation, we
have policies for JSON
to XML, XML to JSON.
We can raise custom
error messages,
check monetization limits.
We can do XSLT and SOAP
message validation.
Assign Message and Extract
Variables I use a lot.
Assign Message lets
me change the request
or the response in some way.
So let's say I want
to insert a header,
or I want to take
something out of a URL
and put it into the body.
I can use that with
Assign Message.
Extract Variables lets
me grab something out
of that request or
response and use it
as a variable inside of Apigee.
Access Entity lets
us load up metadata.
And Key Value Operations lets
us work with the key value map,
so very nice key
value map inside
of Apigee Edge that lets
you store anything that you
need at different scopes.
So, for example, in
here, I store an API key
that I need to talk
to Google Maps.
And I use the key value
map, pull that out of there,
stick it into a request,
and make my call.
So those are the
basic policies that
do things that are very common.
We also have some
extensions in here.
So if you want to do things
in programming languages,
Java, Python, and
JavaScript are supported.
With those languages,
you have complete control
over the request and response.
There's variables in
there to be able to grab
things like headers
and stuff like that.
Or the body content--
you can change it
around and replace it.
We'll see an example
of that in my demo.
Service Callout lets
me do an HTTP callout
before I call the backend.
So, for example, in
my demo I use that.
When I type in the
location of a city,
it makes a callout
to Google Maps
and returns a latitude
and longitude,
and then sends that
to the backend.
Flow Callout lets me
execute a sheared flow.
So let's say I've
got a flow that I
want to use in many of these
different APIs proxies.
I could build a
shared flow for that.
And I access it
with a Flow Callout.
That lets me reuse code.
The Statistics
Collector will allow
me to store a variable
in the analytic system.
So if I want to build
a custom report,
I can grab data from
this custom variable.
And I can show over a
custom report with that.
I can log something
to a logging system.
Maybe if this rate limit is hit
too often, I might log that.
And then there's a
number of extensions
that we can use that make
our backend systems easier
to work with.
So that's the basic policies
that are available to you.
Let's look at a few of
the policies I used.
First thing I'm going to do in
here is check for an API key.
And I'm looking for an API
key as a query parameter.
If I don't get one, this is
going to return an Unauthorized
error.
I'm rate limiting.
I'm limiting somebody to 10
calls per minute in here.
If they call faster than
that, we'll return an error.
I'm checking a quota.
The quota is based
off of an API product.
So we can have different
quotas for different people
calling this.
We've got a response
cache in there.
So if I already have
the answer to this,
if somebody sends me the
same request in a row,
I'm going to grab
that from memory.
And there's my
shared flow that's
going to log me
into Google Cloud.
So that's a few things I do
with every call that comes in.
This flow is where I
look up weather stations.
So someone specified
a particular location,
an airport, or a city,
or something like that.
And I want to find weather
stations that are near there.
So the first thing
I do is, I'm going
to make a call to Google Maps.
But I need something
before that.
I need my API key that
gets me into Google Maps.
So I'm looking that up
from the key value map.
From there, I'm going
to construct a request.
And I'm going to send
that address or location
into Google Maps.
I'm going to ask it what's
the latitude and longitude.
And I need to pass along
an API key to identify me.
And then I'll call
this URL down here.
That's going to respond
back with a description
and the location.
And that has a lot of
information in there.
There's two pieces
of information
that I'm really interested in.
Really the only thing
I want out of there
is the latitude and longitude
of that particular location.
So that is buried in
a certain section.
That's under geometry.location.
And underneath there are
latitude and longitude.
So I've got a JSON
path in here to show
where those variables are.
And then I'm going to store the
values of those in lat and lon.
Next, I'll construct
a bounding box
around that particular location.
So what this JavaScript
code is going to do
is create four variables down
there-- a minimum longitude,
a minimum latitude,
a maximum longitude,
and a maximum latitude.
And those are
stored as variables
that I can then access
later in the flow.
That's what all this code does.
And then next, I'll
construct the query in here.
So I've taken all
this information
that I have gathered,
and I've used
that to build this query up.
Now, when somebody called this,
they just sent to location.
And it didn't have
anything to do
with databases or any kind
of query language or anything
like that.
So I'm taking the
request that was sent
in that contained that address.
I've gone and looked it up,
and calculated some latitudes
and longitudes.
And I've built this query.
And that's what I'm going
to send to the backend.
So that goes to the backend.
I've completely replaced the
payload in here with this.
That goes to the backend.
And then we'll get a response.
And then down here, I
reformat the response
so that it looks a
little bit nicer.
So I'm really just taking
the code that comes back
and reformatting it to
make a little bit nicer.
And I'm sorting it by distance.
So that's the basic flow.
If we go in a little
more detail here,
we want to look up when
somebody has a weather station,
and they make a request,
what does that look like?
So they make a call in
with slash temperature.
And they're going to supply
a few things on the URL.
I need to grab that
data off of the URL.
And then I'm going
to go and find
the data for that particular
weather station in that year.
So this first
policy here is going
to grab the variables
they need from the URL.
So they're calling
slash stations.
They've supplied a weather
station ID right there,
and it's followed by years.
And then a particular
year is supplied there.
So I want to grab these
two pieces of information
and store them as variables.
And then my next step in here
is to build a query for this.
And I'm going to send
that into BigQuery.
And it's going to return
a big set of data for me.
And again, I've replaced the
request with a different one.
This is a Statistics Collector.
And it's going to save the
weather station ID in case
I want a report on
traffic by weather station
ID to see which weather
stations are popular.
So that's how I
built my API proxy.
This is a bit more
complicated than what
most people would build.
Most people are going to
take a backend service.
And they might just be
collecting a security token
and then sending the response
back without any modification.
And it's a great place to start.
I wanted to show this
to you because it
shows all of the different
things you could do
with Apigee if you wanted to.
Much simpler things can be
done, and that's a lot easier.
So when I was building this,
it didn't quite work at first.
I had the request
in the wrong format.
And when I sent it to
BigQuery on the backend,
it returned an error.
And what I realized was,
something in my request
was a little bit off.
So I ran over to the
Trace tool over here.
And this helped me debug.
Let's start a trace session
and see how this works.
So I'm going to click on
the button there to start up
my trace session.
And then I'm going to go
out to my client application
and send in a few requests.
Let's go back to something
that's not cached
and see how that looks.
So we'll see requests start to
come streaming through in here.
I'll run a few of these so
we have a variety of results.
So here we see a call entering.
And this one is for
temperature data
for 2014 for this
particular weather station.
And there's our API
key on the end of that.
So we see this coming in.
We see the request content.
Let's look at the steps and
see how it got that way.
So there's the API key check.
What we're seeing in
here is a whole bunch
of information about this.
So when the API key is
evaluated by Apigee,
it loads up a ton of metadata.
And you can use these.
All these become
variables in here.
And they can be used throughout
your flow for different things.
Maybe you want to
dynamically route somebody
to a different server based on
some sort of metadata that's
associated with this key.
We'll see the spike arrest and
the quota policy being checked.
It's looking to see
if we have the cache.
There's a False there to say
it wasn't found in cache.
And then this is
my shared flow that
authorizes me with BigQuery.
We'll see the variables
being extracted.
And then the final
request is sent in.
And we can see that this
looks very different.
So we saw it came
in as a GET here.
And then it went out like this.
So we're seeing it
turned into a POST.
So there's the POST.
And that's what's going
out to the backend.
We see the response coming back.
So we can see the format
of the data that's
returned from BigQuery.
So we can see that I changed
that around a little bit,
made it a little bit
cleaner and easier
for the developer to understand.
So that's a basic flow in here.
The second one, we'll
notice, is a bit shorter.
And that's because
we're hitting cache,
so the response has
been returned to us
straight from cache.
And it's a lot faster too.
Here's our rate limiting.
So in this case,
Apigee Edge detected
that this is being called too
quickly, and it shut it down.
So I've got this spike arrest
right here that was tripped.
And then we'll see that a custom
error message is sent back.
And it says, call rate
exceeded, this application
is limited to 10
requests per minute.
And that will give our
developer a pretty good hint
about what's going on.
So you have a good idea of
exactly what went wrong.
Now, when I was
building this API proxy,
I found out that I had
something a little bit wrong
in that query.
So I had gotten a quote
in the wrong place,
and so BigQuery
was rejecting it.
And I saw that in
the Trace tool.
When I looked at the
payload, I could see
that the mistake was in there.
I went back and fixed it.
So this was really
helpful for me.
It helped me find that
mistake in a big hurry,
and I was able to fix it.
So that's how we would
debug and trace something.
The next thing to think
about is publishing.
How do we take
this and publish it
out so that somebody can use it?
So I want to talk about the
concept of API products.
And this will become
important when
we start to think about
how to publish our APIs out
for consumption.
So we use API products
in Apigee Edge
to share your APIs
with consumers.
And let's think about
this for a minute.
We're not just thinking
about services anymore.
These are now becoming products.
And so there's a whole
lifecycle of these APIs
that people want to consume.
We've got to think about
how we might manage that.
So we're going to take a
formal approach to this,
and we're going to think
of these as products.
And a product might contain
more than one service.
So what that looks like
inside of Apigee Edge
is, we've got those APIs
proxies over there on the left.
And that's what you saw
me walking through here.
I got this particular
Weather API.
And I can have a
number of products
that give access to that.
So I have Silver access, Gold
access, and Platinum access
as an example here.
And they give you
different entitlements.
And those are different
metadata that's
associated with those products.
So Silver gives us
100 calls per day
with 5 calls per minute
and some limited access.
We can only do some things.
So, for example, I might
only be able to look up
weather stations, but I can't
get temperature or wind data.
And Gold access might
entitle me to more calls.
And it would give me full access
to all those different things
that are in the APIs.
So I have a series
of these products,
but people don't
have access yet.
If I want to grant somebody
access to call this API,
I'm going to register
an application.
So let's say we're building the
Android application for looking
at weather history.
I'd register my application
and some metadata associated
with that.
And that would generate
some keys for me
that I could use to
call into the system.
So you register an
application, and that gives you
access to one or more products.
And those products
have entitlements
to use certain APIs.
So we don't just have a
service, and everybody calls it,
and we don't know who's who.
We're going to have a system
in here for managing products.
And we give people
access to these products.
They have API keys,
or they're going
to be sending OAuth
tokens or JWTs.
And that lets us track
exactly who's calling things.
So where do we get these keys?
We create an API product
inside of Apigee,
where you decide
which proxies are
going to go in there and
which resources of those.
From there, we register
a developer application.
And a developer can have access
to more than one API product.
And that generates two
keys-- a consumer key
and a consumer secret key.
And you use the consumer
key as your API key.
Or you're going to use
both keys if you're going
to generate an OAuth token.
So that's a quick
overview of API products.
Let's go back and see how
we do that inside of Apigee.
So let's click over
here on the box.
And we'll see that
in this section,
we've got something
called API Products.
And I'll show you an
API product that I've
built for my Weather demo.
So we have the Weather History--
Try it out down here.
And let me put this in edit
mode so you can see what
it was like when I created it.
So I called this
Weather History--
Try it.
And it provides 100 calls per
day for development usage.
And the access is
public, meaning
it'll show up on my portal.
I've got 100 requests for every
one day, and that's the quota.
This describes what's
available in my API.
So anybody who
calls that you URL,
I could specify in here
something a little more
detailed, like slash
temperature or slash stations,
if I wanted to.
And then we can see down here
all the different developer
apps that make use
of this product.
Let's look at the
webcast-demo-app.
So here's our application.
We can see that it's
usage was approved.
And we have a key
and a secret that we
can use for calling this.
If I wanted to add
custom attributes,
I can do so down here.
I might have partner ID on there
or something like that that's
meaningful to my business.
And whenever this API
key comes through here,
that variable
would be loaded up.
And I can use it for logging,
or for traffic redirection,
or figuring out
how to limit them,
or whatever I want
to do with it.
So this is one way to create
an application and register it.
You can do it by hand in here.
And I can register this
for a particular developer.
I send these credentials
to the developer,
and they're good to go.
But another way to do that,
probably a more common way
to do that, is that the
developer would do this.
And they're going to do that
using a Developer Portal.
So our third perspective
is the API team.
Let's look at how
they would use Apigee
to manage their API program.
The API team has an interest in
knowing how things are running.
So they may come in to
the Analyze tab over here
and look at some
of these reports.
The first one we'll look at
here is Proxy Performance.
And this is just
going to show us
the very basics, so how
much traffic did we get,
what was the average
response time, what's
the traffic by proxy, and
what's the average response
time by proxy--
so quick high-level
summary of what's going on.
I could change the
dimension up here from hour
to day of the week or
some custom time period.
Another report that
might be interesting
is Developer Engagement, so
who is writing applications.
So we've got 10 total
developers that are registered.
Seven have registered
applications.
And four are highly active--
or four are active and
two are highly active.
This gives us an idea of
who's using the system
and who's going to be
using it in the future.
The Devices report is going to
show us what kind of devices
people are using, so who's
on which type of browser.
Are they on a mobile device?
Are they on a desktop?
Are they running Chrome or
are they running Firefox?
Maybe there's a few folks that
are still on Internet Explorer.
We can see all that
on this report.
And that might help us guide
where we spend our development
in terms of applications.
The map shows us where
traffic is coming from.
So we've got traffic coming
from the United States here
and some calls from Canada.
If we click through, we'll see
the Colorado's highlighting.
That's where I am,
and that's where
I'm sending my request from.
Target Performance
is going to show us
how the backend
system is keeping up.
So this gives us an idea over
time of what the response
time is for the backend system.
And Traffic Composition
will show us our top 10
proxies, top 10
apps, top 10 products
and give us an idea of what's
most popular at this time.
And there's a bunch
more reports in here
that you can look at
that do different things.
You can also build
custom reports.
And you can grab
anything you want out
of the request or the
response and build
a full-featured custom
report that gives you
exactly what you want to see.
Finally, our API team might also
be interested in monitoring.
So they might come over to
the Monitoring dashboard.
And this is where
we could set alerts.
If we want to configure some
alerts and some notifications
when things happen
in the system,
we could do that in here.
This is a whole other topic
that's worth digging into.
But we're going to cut short
on this for interest of time.
So we looked at the demo from
three different perspectives.
We looked at how the
application developer or API
consumer was able to
easily go out to a portal,
learn everything
that was required,
get credentials, and start
building an application
and sending in
traffic very quickly.
The amount of friction
required to build
that first step is very low.
We saw how the API developer
took an existing service,
and started to manage
it with Apigee,
and put some products
in place so it
was easy for these
developers to consume it.
And finally, we saw
how the API team
would look at some
Analytics dashboards,
and monitor how their
program is going,
and use the Monitoring features
to make sure everything's
running smoothly.
So let's take some questions.
So first question
in here is, how
do you do versioning in Apigee?
So good question.
I get this a lot.
So there's quite a bit of
religion around versioning.
What I typically
recommend to people
is that you've got a URL.
And that URL is going to have
the version number in it.
So put a v1 or a v2 in
your URL as far to the left
as you possibly can.
So what you do in Apigee
is, you can take your proxy,
and you can save it
as a new revision.
And then inside
of there, you just
change the URL that
it's listening on.
So you might have one
v1-weather-demo, for example,
or v2-weather-demo.
And then you're free to
change that around as needed.
So that's versioning.
There's also the
concept of revisioning.
So Apigee has a built
in revisioning system.
You might have
noticed in the demo
that I was on revision
7 and 8 in there.
The way that works
is, that's going
to allow you to roll back to
previous versions of your API
proxy.
And in some cases, you
might make changes in there
that I would consider a
revision but not a version.
So I would consider a
version something that breaks
the contract with the client.
And if you change around
the payload that's
sent back in such a way that
it would break the client,
then that needs to be a
new version with a new URL.
If you're just adding
caching or fixing the way
that your proxy works, but
that doesn't necessarily
change the data that
goes back and forth,
that's just a revision.
So those two things together
are going to make up
revisioning and versioning.
Will Apigee export a
proxy to OpenAPI format
as well as import it that way?
You can definitely
import one that way.
There's a whole spec
editor inside of Apigee.
And you can edit
your specs in there,
and you can publish them
out to the portal that way.
We do have some
tools out on GitHub
that will introspect
an existing API proxy
and make an attempt to
generate an OpenAPI spec.
If you work with a WSDL, and
you're doing a SOAP service,
that part of the SOAP wizard
there will automatically
generate one for you.
What about role-based
access control?
How do we keep
people from seeing
stuff they shouldn't see?
Good question.
As I went through this--
I'm the administrator.
And I can see all kinds
of stuff in there,
and I can push to production.
A typical way of doing this
is, there's a role-based access
system in there.
And we would use that to control
what people have access to.
So I might have access to
a staging place or a QA
environment, but I don't
have access to production.
And we might use
service APIs in order
to push things into production.
So we might use the UI for
some of our development work.
But then we're going to check
the source code into Git.
We're going to pull
down from there,
maybe run some tests on it.
And then we'll have that
automatically pushed
into production.
Is it possible to
combine the results
from more than one
backend building
aggregate or a composite?
It is.
So go out on YouTube and
search for "Apigee Up Close."
And you'll find that I did a
whole webcast on that topic.
So just in summary,
what you do is,
you can call out to two
or three backend services.
And then typically, you would
use one of the programming
languages--
Java, JavaScript, or Python--
and build a composite result
in there to send back.
But yeah, we've got a
whole webcast on that.
Is Apigee only for people that
have external API programs?
Do people use it for
internal API programs?
They do.
So yeah, oddly
enough, most people
are using it for
internal API programs.
We have a small subset of people
who have external-facing APIs.
And it's fantastic for that.
But the same kind
of benefits you
might get when you're running
an external API program,
those could be used
inside your company
for people that are
external to your group.
So same concept but
used internally.
Does Apigee support
OpenAPI spec version 3?
Yes, it does.
So yeah, you can try that
out in the spec editor.
Can Apigee return a
different response
based on an Accept header,
for example, JSON or XML?
Yes, that's something
we see pretty commonly.
So let's say you have an
existing SOAP service,
and you want to have that
return either XML or JSON
depending on how
somebody calls it.
So you can put a
condition in there.
And that condition would be
used to determine whether it
runs the XML-to-JSON policy.
And that would return it--
it would behave differently
depending on how you call
it, which header you send in.
So nice way and very easy
to build an intelligent API
like that.
It's going to respond
with what people need.
Can you use Apigee to control
access to a cloud function?
You certainly can, so it's
a common use case for that.
You might have a
service account enabled
for your cloud function.
And then you'd put
Apigee in front of it,
and only Apigee would be able
to access that with credentials.
And then you might manage the
security to the outside world
with OAuth tokens that
are managed by Apigee.
Can you export Analytics
data using an API?
Yes, there's a
whole API in there
for getting an Analytics data.
Check the Apigee documentation,
and within there, you'll
see that there's an API.
You can specify a time range,
and you can pull down Analytics
data programmatically.
Let's say the backend changes.
Can you pre-populate or
invalidate that cache
that you're using in there?
So yes, you can.
There's policies to adjust
the cache programmatically.
You could also run
that through the UI.
There's a tool in there
to flush the cache.
And you can do it through
a service API, where
you call the cache directly.
And you could pre-populate
it or you could flush it
if the backend is changed.
Can you route traffic to
different backend servers
based on something you
know about the identity
of the calling application?
So, for example,
partner A and partner B
both call the same URL,
but they should be routed
to different backend servers.
Sure.
So what is typically
done in there
is, when you generate an
API key or an OAuth token,
you can apply custom
metadata to that.
So you would put in
there something that
lets you know which
partner this is
or gives an idea of some sort
of identity that you can use.
That becomes a variable
when their call comes in.
So as soon as that processes
the OAuth token or the API key,
that data is loaded
as a variable.
And you have a
condition in there.
And you can supply multiple
backend targets inside
of Apigee, and you can
set up a route rule.
So that's all built
in to do that.
You would look at that attribute
and then route to A or B
based on that.
Is it possible to have different
quotas for the same API?
So, for example,
person A and person B
both called the same URL but
are limited in different ways.
It is.
So oftentimes, we'd put a
quota on the API product.
And then, when you
go to generate a key,
you would either choose
one product or the other,
depending on what you
want that quota to be.
So when those two people call
that API using different API
keys, they'd be rate
limited differently.
What are the key features
of an API Gateway?
So I made a point in
here of distinguishing
between a Gateway and an
API management platform.
A Gateway tends to be
more security focused.
So this is the
gateway that we're
going to use to let people in.
And it's going to check OAuth
tokens and send them along
if they have one and
block them if they don't.
So a Gateway tends to be more
around that, more networking
based.
And then an API
management platform
is considering all these people.
So it expands on the
Gateway with the ability
to manage developers,
to manage keys,
to have Analytics
and things like that.
So that's a much bigger
solution than a simple gateway.
Sometimes, a Gateway
is appropriate for what
you're doing, and sometimes
you need a full API management
solution.
So question in here about what
is the use of custom attributes
and products.
Can you share an example
where that's useful?
So yeah, that goes back
to the other question.
When I created an API product,
I might put a key on there.
And that's going to be
propagated to all the apps
that are generated.
So basically, that
attribute will go on
to any keys that are
generated for apps.
And then it comes
through as a variable.
And you might use that for
conditional expressions.
So you might have a policy
that either executes
or doesn't based on that.
Or you may have routing rules
based on that to send them
to different places.
Or the quota might be
enforced based on that.
I think that's about all
we've got for time today.
So we can go ahead
and wrap it up.
Thank you so much
for attending today.
We appreciate it.
We'll see you in
the next webcast.